next question is from Kenny have you
ever been tricked by a scam be it phone
online or by product advertisement I
think by product advertisements in some
sense I've been tricked in that I've
made product buying decisions based on
self self professed claims about a
product or service from the provider of
that product or service and it wasn't a
good product or service and I don't know
that I would call that having been
tricked by a scam I mean certainly there
were times in my younger days where I
would learn about an amway cutco type
pyramid scheme effectively is what it is
I'm sorry they call it multi-level
marketing enough to receive the term
pyramid scheme pyramid schemes are
illegal and not allowed you know what
I'm talking about I never actually went
in on it and paid whatever the initial
initiation fee was but I did start to
look into it in pretty significant
detail where I thought it was going to
be a great thing and it was going to be
a good business opportunity for me but I
stopped short I did talk about that
apparel business I've told the story
before that I invested in when I was
like 19 years old and it was absolutely
and utterly bogus in terms of a real a
bona fide company with potential for
return and I learned a lot doing that
was I tricked by a scam I was certainly
convinced into making an investment that
was not a good investment so in a sense
I guess I was tricked I think I'm good
at telling what a scam is when I see it
right away but sometimes I just want to
believe it's so badly that will
investigate more and more into it yeah I
saw an apartment listing on craigslist
for six hundred dollars a month in
arlington massachusetts it's not that
out there but that does seem very very
low for the area a normal apartment here
maybe eight hundred to a thousand twelve
good I mean it depends obviously but you
know something that's affordable this
was quite so low that range and then
they say hey you know what does that
apartment is not available but I've had
a different one I can show you that's a
common craigslist apartments can well no
because I think they said that they
lived in Texas so I would be sending
them the money probable first month's
rent the last month's rent and the a
security deposit and then I would get
nothing in return it was a total scam I
mean
I was never going to send them money
without you know checking everything out
but yeah I was I wanted to believe it to
a point where I even looked into it that
why many scams are effective because
you're praying upon what will be clearly
someone's desire to believe that it's
true either because something that would
normally be unaffordable is being
proposed to them as affordable or
because something you know it could be a
product or whatever the case may be and
usually if it's too good to be true it
is yeah but these people think well I'm
actually kind of scamming them because
they don't realize that they're missing
out on a great opportunity here I'm you
know doing something smart from all this
right turns out it's just too good to be
true yeah and and in my experience if it
even seems a little bit too good to be
true it almost always is I've never
fallen for like the IRS phone scams
where they say you I'm from the IRS eos
money I've never fallen for the your
computer has a virus let us fix it for
you and then they take your computer
files hostage and make you pay a ransom
to release the money I've never fallen
for the electricity broker scams that
are now really common in Massachusetts
because of deregulation I know you get
some of those calls oh absolutely the
same ones over and over again actually
have to go I asked to speak to a
Nigerian prince whose promised me quite
a lot sometimes I used to when I had
more time on my hands now I don't even
have the time to consider doing these
things when i would get those like I'm
barrister whatever and I work with a
very rich family in Nigeria and we've
got five million dollars that we need
your help getting out we just need you
to send a check for three grand for the
legal fees blah blah blah blah blah I
used to respondent am super interested
let's discuss how can we do this blah
blah blah blah blah I don't have the
time for that nonsense anymore I do it
you you still do I mean if there's a
court recording i'll go ahead and try to
get an actual person to speak with me
right this happened about a week ago
after they played the recording i spoke
with an actual person oh yes and they
said could I ask for your name please
and I said you could ask and then they
hung up oh and that was it that was it
for a while i was having people call me
offering me a warranty on a car that i
hadn't had for years they kept calling
me and i said i don't have the car take
me off the list i don't have a car take
me off the list
once I said you know what fine let's
just see what happens I'm like yes that
sounds interesting let's discuss they
said oh we've got a live one here they
transferred me to a Senior Account
Executive we started talking to me about
the insurance and all these different
things and he said okay and blah blah
blah blah blah we were I kept the guy on
the phone 10 or 15 minutes and
eventually he moved on to the payment
phase and I go great yeah let's pay for
it one question does it matter that I
haven't had this car for years and he
says confused what uh yeah i yeah you
but you don't have the car and said you
guys have called me 10 or 12 times in
the last few months and every single
time i tell you i do not own this car
and you tell me you won't call me again
since you kept calling i assumed I could
get the warranty anyway even though I
don't have the car guy hung up never
heard from them since that's what they
deserve I mean I'm sure they're so
excited once they finally get someone to
go along with their scam yeah and if you
can waste their time for 10 minutes
you're leaving a lot of people from
getting called that disc right if
they're calling someone every 20 seconds
10 minutes could be saving a lot of
people from getting a phone call better
being a good Samaritan bonus show got to
be a member to get the bonus show but
it's great it's Bigley tremendous that's
what I've read on the internet from
completely anonymous sources which I'm
fundamentally against as its Trump about
the bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code i voted 17